僕はこれまでに巨大スーパーボールを作る動画
嫌ほどやってきました
だが、どれも失敗に終わっている。
僕は何度やっても何度やっても…
何度やっても何度やっても…失敗
ジレッとプログライド
何度やっても何度やっても失敗する。
そんな僕にも、新しい希望の光が来ました
今回はこちら
おゆまるです
これが何か分かるか？
私もそんな詳しいわけじゃないんだよ
ただ、なんとなく調べてたらあって
これはプラスチック粘土って言うのかな？
ちょっと見ていきましょう
お湯で温めれば形が変わるらしいです。
24個入ってるみたいですね。
ほらきたァ！ここ！...スーパーボール
よく弾むスーパーボールができるって書いてありますよォォオオ！！
来たぞ、これだ
これを待っていた
作り方なんですけども
書いてある通り
熱いお湯にこれを入れれば
形が動かせるようになるらしいです
は？！
熱いお湯に入れて
３分ぐらいで柔らかくなるらしいんですけど
熱いお湯が８０℃以上らしいです…
待って待って、８０℃ってさ
お風呂じゃダメだよね…
もうちょ、ちょっとお湯止めてくるわ…
５０℃ぐらいかと思ってたー、お湯止めてくる
お風呂のお湯じゃダメかー
ガチなやつじゃん…
はい、というわけでおゆまる、８０℃以上ということで
お風呂にバッとね、入れようと思ったんですけど
ダメみたいです
熱いお湯８０℃以上なので
ちょっと皆さん作る時は温度に気を付けましょう
危ないからね！
今日はこのおゆまるを使って
このおゆまるのセットを１０個準備しました
合計２４０個のおゆまるを使って
いけるよ、いけるよ！
ってか、いかねーと困る、そろそろ
今回はいけるでしょう！
スーパーボールが作れる、よく弾むって書いてあるんすよ
それを２４０個準備して
全部熱湯にぶちこんで
全部動かせるようにして
全部くっつけて
巨大なスーパーボールの出来上がりっすよ
うわ、すごい…めっちゃフツーにキレイなんですけど
ああ、ああ…触った感じはスーパーボールです
弾力は…うわ！
弾力はちゃんとあります
いける、いける、いける
ハイ、というわけで全部出ました
これはなかなかいいっしょ
いや、これ物量的には完全に
超巨大スーパーボール作れるレベルの量あると思います
では行こう！
マジでそろそろ成功させたいんで
巨大スーパーボールはなんか物理的に
不可能なのかなとか思ってきたりしてるんで
今日ので、ちょっとバヨーンと跳ねてほしいと
思っております
ハイ、というわけで早速お湯の中に入れていきましょう
みんな入れーー！
これ大丈夫かなー？ちょっと強くね？
うわ、うわこれさ
おゆまる死んじゃうよー、熱すぎて
ちょっと、早速この熱湯の中に
おゆまるを入れてみましょう
まあ入れる事によってどのように変わるかが
すごいポイントっすね
３分ぐらいで柔らかくなるらしいです
全部、もう結構入れちゃっていい？
結構入れちゃうよ？
あつあつあつ…あっつ！あつあつ…
ちょっと１部と２部に分けよう
ってか、加熱
もうちょいお湯増やそうかな…
お湯が全然足りねーな…
よし、OK、OK
これで、ちょっと３分ぐらい待ってみましょう
結構ふにゃってきました
ここら辺とかね
おめーはふにゃってねーや
基本的にお湯にちゃんと入ってるやつは
結構ふにゃってきてるんで
もうそろそろ形が作れるのかなと思います
えー、待って、もうちょっと、ちょっとだけ、と、取ってみよう
うわ、うわ、待ってお前ら
待って、お前らさ…
あー、待って、お前ら、このままじゃなんか
このまま形になるよ、待って待って
あー、お前ら
これは…ま、待てる、待てやー
とりあえず水分を取らなきゃいけないから
タオルを敷く
もう、とり、取り出すよ、取りだ、取りだ
もうこれ取り出すしかないよね
あー！
オッケー、取り出せました
待ってよ、完全に
異世界の物体じゃん
ねえ、完全にグロい、完全にグロい
残りのやつを全部入れましょう
あっち！
２発目全部入りました
この間に俺はてめーの水分を取る
水分を取ってから形を作るらしいです
今のうちにしっかり水分を取りましょう
あっつ！
熱い、待って、早く
早く取んないと…早く取んないとでも
早く…ちょっと待って
餅つきみたいになっちゃった…
待って、ホントに…あの
ビックリするくらい熱いんで！
よし、取るぞ、お前の…
形を作る！
ほっ！ほっほっ！
あー、忙しい…
忙しい…お前も頑張れ…
もうすぐ仲間が来る！
よし、じゃあ第２波いきましょう
よし、じゃあいきます
せーの
あー、あっあっあっあっ…
待った、タンマ
あぶね、あぶね、お箸落としちゃった
せーの、ほっ！
あっつ！
オッケー、パーフェクト
お湯は危ないから捨てる
あらー…
よし、来たぞー
水分を取りましょう
あっつ！
あっつー…
取り出した第２波と
１波を合体させて
巨大スーパーボールの形を、もう作っちゃいます
来たぞーー！
ついに時代が来てる気がするぞ
まずはしっかり丸めていくことが大事ですねー
♪おいしいパンを～作ろう～♪
あっ！あっあっ…
ちょ、熱っ！今なんで…
な、なにが…え、待って
いや、待った、なんでー？
中から熱湯が出てきたよ
温泉かよ！
普通に今やけど、今やけどだよ
中にまだ水分がいたってことか…
もういいかなー…？
もはや未確認生物になってしまったんですけど
水は取れたんで、丸めていきましょう
よし、まあこんなもんっしょ！
一応スーパーボールはできましたが
置いておくとどんどん形がね
また崩れてくんですよ
よし…
では冷蔵庫行ってきます
(笑い声)
できました、おゆまるで作った巨大スーパーボールです
冷凍庫に入れて一気に冷やしたんで
硬くて、もう形も崩れません
…ちょっといびつです
だって書いてあるんだもん！
「よく弾むスーパーボールができるよ」って！
これ間違いないっしょ！
ではいきます！
あぶなーい！
待って待って、跳ねた！
でも跳ねたよ
跳ねたよね？
パソコン！
危ない！危ない…
今から乱数的な動きをするから
弾道力は完全にスーパーボール
これは成功かもしれないぞ！
いや、すげーよ！
あっ！うっ！うっ！うっ！痛っ！！